is going to be when he's Messi
sprinting down the pitch
putting the ball in the back of the net,
or Federer serving in Wimbledon?
What do you think his experience is going to be
when he is going down the side of a mountain
at over 70 miles an hour
as an Olympic downhill skier?
I think adult diaper sales may surge.
(Laughter)
But this is not yet augmented reality.
This is only virtual reality, V.R.
How do we get to augmented reality, A.R.?
We get to augmented reality
when coaches and managers and owners
look at this information streaming in
that people want to see, and they say,
"How do we use this to make our teams better?
How do we use this to win games?"
Because teams always use technology to win games.
They like winning. It makes them money.
So a brief history of technology in the NFL.
In 1965, the Baltimore Colts
put a wristband on their quarterback
to allow him to call plays quicker.
They ended up winning a Super Bowl that year.
Other teams followed suit.
More people watched the game because it was more exciting.
It was faster.
In 1994, the NFL put helmet radios
into the helmets of the quarterbacks,
and later the defense.
More people watched games because it was faster.
It was more entertaining.
In 2023, imagine you're a player
walking back to the huddle,
and you have your next play displayed
right in front of your face on your clear plastic visor
that you already wear right now.
No more having to worry about forgetting plays.
No more worrying about having to memorize your playbook.
You just go out and react.
And coaches really want this,
because missed assignments lose you games,
and coaches hate losing games.
Losing games gets you fired as a coach.
They don't want that.
But augmented reality is not just
an enhanced playbook.
Augmented reality is also a way to take all that data
and use it in real time
to enhance how you play the game.
What would that be like?
Well, a very simple setup would be a camera
on each corner of the stadium looking down,
giving you a bird's-eye view
of all the people down there.
You also have information from helmet sensors
and accelerometers,
technology that's being worked on right now.
You take all that information, and you stream it to your players.
The good teams stream it in a way that the players can use.
The bad ones have information overload.
That determines good teams from bad.
And now, your I.T. department
is just as important as your scouting department,
and data-mining is not for nerds anymore.
It's also for jocks. Who knew?
What would that look like on the field?
Well, imagine you're the quarterback.
You take the snap and you drop back.
You're scanning downfield for an open receiver.
All of a sudden, a bright flash
on the left side of your visor lets you know,
blind side linebacker is blitzing in.
Normally, you wouldn't be able to see him,
but the augmented reality system lets you know.
You step up into the pocket.
Another flash alerts you to an open receiver.
You throw the ball, but you're hit right as you throw.
The ball comes off track.
You don't know where it's going to land.
However, on the receiver's visor,
he sees a patch of grass light up,
and he knows to readjust.
He goes, catches the ball,
sprints in, touchdown.
Crowd goes wild, and the fans are with him
every step of the way,
watching from every perspective.
Now this is something that will create
massive excitement in the game.
It will make tons of people watch,
because people want this experience.
Fans want to be on the field.
They want to be their favorite player.
Augmented reality will be a part of sports,
because it's too profitable not to.
But the question I ask you is,
is that's all that we're content to use augmented reality for?
Are we going to use it solely for our panem,
our circenses, our entertainment as normal?
Because I believe that we can use augmented reality
for something more.
I believe we can use augmented reality
as a way to foster more empathy
within the human species itself,
by literally showing someone
what it looks like
to walk a mile in another person's shoes.
We know what this technology is worth
to sports leagues.
It's worth revenue, to the tune of billions of dollars a year.
But what is this technology worth
to a teacher in a classroom
trying to show a bully
just how harmful his actions are
from the perspective of the victim?
What is this technology worth
to a gay Ugandan or Russian
trying to show the world what it's like
living under persecution?
What is this technology worth
to a Commander Hadfield or a Neil deGrasse Tyson
trying to inspire a generation of children
to think more about space and science
instead of quarterly reports and Kardashians?
Ladies and gentlemen, augmented reality
is coming.
The questions we ask, the choices we make,
and the challenges we face
are, as always, up to us.
Thank you.
(Applause)